[Música]
bienvenidos a directo 26 el espacio de
france 24 dedicado a entender a
profundidad qué está pasando en la
cumbre climática de la onu en glasgow de
lunes a sábado tenemos a este espacio
con una de nuestras enviadas especiales
marina colorado buenas tardes marina un
gusto de nuevo conectar con usted y hoy
comienza una de las discusiones más
difíciles de la cob 26 sobre la
financiación cuéntenos qué está pasando
al respecto
pues ya se han terminado estas
negociaciones las primeras después de
que los líderes mundiales se marcharán
de glasgow escocia hoy como bien lo
decía será el día dedicado a las
finanzas y al ok sharma el presidente de
la cve 26 y ministro de energía de reino
unido dijo estar que era lamentable que
no se hubiera alcanzado el objetivo
impuesto en 2009 de alcanzar los 100 mil
millones de dólares de financiamiento
por parte de países ricos para ayudar a
los países con menos recursos económicos
a conseguir que su economía esté menos
basada en economía en combustibles
fósiles y también para que se puedan
adaptar y mitigar los efectos del cambio
climático sin embargo dijo sentirse
cautelosamente optimista de que este
objetivo se va a poder conseguir en 2022
ya que hubo nuevos anuncios de
compromisos de españa irlanda y
luxemburgo datos de la ocde sin embargo
dicen que no se bancan a alcanzar hasta
2023 ya que en 2019 las cifras eran de
80 mil millones de dólares según la lox
arma fue un buen comienzo sin embargo
desde climate action network una
asociación de 1500 asociaciones
ambientales de la sociedad civil
critican la falta de detalles concretos
para ver cómo van a recaudar este dinero
para poder conseguir esas promesas de
los políticos sin embargo del sector
privado llegan noticias de 450
organizaciones que componen el 40 por
ciento de los recursos económicos del
mundo han prometido
130 millones de dólares en la próxima
década para ayudar a que las economías
estén basadas en energías más limpias y
precisamente hablando de las
organizaciones del sector privado usted
está con felipe cano el presidente de
global carbón parks
correcto y global albert park es el
primer contrato público privado de
comercialización de carbono en áreas
protegidas subnacionales como bien
decías me acompaña el presidente de esta
organización
felipe cano a felipe explíquenos en qué
consiste y cómo funcionan estos modelos
de economía bueno muchísimas gracias
marina por invitarme ya era hora que nos
conociéramos personalmente básicamente
lo que hemos tratado de crear es un
protocolo para descarbonizar urbanamente
pero tomando como el primer pilar del
desarrollo descarbonización áreas
protegidas las áreas protegidas como el
bien dicho dice que los árboles en los
árboles no crecen dinero pues ahora en
los árboles producen dinero entonces
estamos cogiendo las áreas protegidas
estamos creando una estructuración de
proyectos financieros basados en la
monetización de estos carbón créditos o
bonos de carbonos que utilizamos
eventualmente en una economía circular
inyectando ese dinero para descarbonizar
urbanamente en el área local el
protocolo basado a base de data y tiene
un reporte de impacto para poder llegar
a ser transparente e inmutable
impacto que creemos
derivado de la descarbonización de los
árboles y cuál es el potencial económico
del mercado de carbono y los beneficios
para la región de latinoamérica
bueno moderadamente podemos hablar entre
300 a 500 billones de dólares pero si de
asilo si lo hacemos de una manera un
poco más agresiva yo creo que podríamos
alcanzar un trillón de mil billones de
dólares o sea un billón de dólares en
español
bueno un trillón de dólares en dólares
es básicamente mil millones de videos
mil billones de dólares y realmente para
los que no conocen bien cómo funciona
esto es decir ustedes ponen en contacto
al sector privado con el público cómo
funciona es bueno eso es lo que se llama
un private pobre partner un acuerdo
entre lo público y lo privado en el cual
ellos nos suministran la capacidad de
comercializar ya sea de una parte en
análoga y una parte digital y nosotros
con nuestros vendedores los vendemos y
cuando adquirimos ese procedimiento esa
utilidad de la venta de los carbonos
transmitimos en un porcentaje bastante
alto al país región o ciudad para
empezar su descarbonización básicamente
desde abajo hacia arriba porque en el
protocolo tenemos asignado un estudio
previo para medir la polución y la
electrificación en ese modo en ese monto
creamos una estrategia boston a la
medida por cada ciudad o región ese ese
dinero va lo descarbonizada mos probamos
y también mostramos el impacto tanto
local estatal y a nivel mundial pues
estaremos muy pendientes de cómo
evoluciona esta nueva manera de hacer
comercio por así decirlo de manera verde
y utilizando los recursos naturales de
la región de latinoamérica muchísimas
gracias felipe cano por su tiempo en
france 24 centrado y a ustedes
muchísimas gracias es todo aquí en
directo con 26 desde glasgow escocia
gracias marina y gracias felipe por esta
información sobre el protocolo para
descarbonizar urbanamente ustedes sigan
conectados a la señal de france 24 y
esperen las emisiones de directo con 26
de lunes a sábado a la una y cuarto de
la tarde en hora de bogotá quito lima
hasta la próxima
[Música]